are you ready to fly down the slopes and
steep are you ready to pay a little
extra for more of that stuff I'm Tony
and this is your snow-covered GameSpot
news update steep season pass and DLC
plans have been announced
first up the adrenaline pack as night
challenges glow-in-the-dark costumes and
additional outfits the Winter Fest pack
adds more challenges in costumes plus
winter sledding as a new sport finally
the extreme pack adds even more
challenges and three new sports rocket
wings BASE jumping and speed gliding all
of these are included in the game's $20
season pass available on all platforms
the pass will also net you 10,000 and
game credits 10 helicopter tickets and
the exclusive snowman costume individual
prices and release dates for the DLC
packs haven't been given yet Steve comes
to ps4 Xbox one and PC on December 2nd
and if you're watching this on or after
launch date hopefully you're enjoying
the ride to keep up with all the latest
on steep and Ubisoft you're already in
the right place